what it means to me is carrying on
Michael Jordan's legacy on and off the
court he's an anomaly not many people
have done what he's done in an industry
period point blank in the store hi I'm
Reggie Saunders vice president of
entertainment influencer marketing for
the Jordan brand and this is my life in
sneakers
it wasn't something I said oh I'm going
to start collecting Sneakers but I know
when I realized when I look in the
bottom of my closet as a 14 year old 15
year old I was like oh man I got a lot
of sneakers you know I grew up my father
was in the Army I was born on an army
base in Fort Bragg North Carolina I'm a
country boy at heart but when we moved
to the DMV area all of a sudden the city
thing started kicking in and I was
seeing different things I'm here in
Baltimore house music I'm here in DC go
go I was pop trying to Pop Lock And
Windmill and backspins and you know I'm
walking around with my cardboard in a
boom box I do remember
my first real Footlocker experience I
pick up these shoes in their white low
top ponies with a blue check and his
signature on the back was David Thompson
my dad's like
I'm not spending 47.99 on those sneakers
there's no way son full circle Michael
Jordan had David Thompson present him at
the hall of fame because it was his
favorite player that David Thompson Pony
was it for me a lot of people don't know
this but I originally signed with NC
State to play football my dream and it
got cut short because my mom got breast
cancer if I went to North Carolina state
is this conversation might not be
happening and I remember my mom saying
what are you going to do with the Sports
Marketing degree I don't I don't
understand and I'm like ah no no Mom
like it's like a corporation like they
have accounting they have marketing they
have public relations she's like okay
all right well let's see where this goes
and years later I was working for an
agency that represented the Jordan brand
but I had a key card in my pocket I had
a Jordan showroom and people trusted me
because when they came they were getting
oh free T-Mobile service and then I
could leave with some Jordans for my
girl too she didn't get something yeah
yeah I got to work on the 16 and the 17
and the 18 launches and that's when
everything started coming to fruition
and then Larry Miller and H white were
talking to Michael one day he's like hey
you know this kid he works for us right
there like no he works for the agency
that represents he's a wait what and
then Larry and H said to Michael yeah we
don't need the agency we need Ranch
[Music]
I don't know like they just think oh
they just gave them friends and family
there's always a business reason behind
it right if you're looking at these
Runners with Travis Scott and Cactus
Jack here on the side he loved the
trunner and we were talking performance
at the time and the Toronto was coming
out in the marketplace and we just for
friends and family trainers I still
think we need to bring these back
somehow this needs to be a shock drop
hello sneakers folks and this is when
tribe wasn't into that brown palette
this was him saying man I love the
trainer bro that's his era and I still
wear them to this day and I love him if
you talk to Travis Scott he'll say to me
I perform in the same Arenas I even have
more fans because I use their floor for
seats every athlete wants to be an
Entertainer every Entertainer Wants To
Be An Athlete the middle point for me is
the Jumpman
[Music]
let's go Eminem my brother Slim Shady it
was actually the 10th anniversary eight
mile that's what these shoes were
originally for we missed the date and
then I think it was the 20th anniversary
of Shady Records the first sample we got
back had Chrome back here and Marshall
wanted to keep it him and Paul Rosenberg
we played off of the Chrome here they
wanted to keep it cohesive M's really
good at that Paul Rosenberg is really
good at that so we changed the tabs to
Black and that's why this tab is what I
had to send to them to get approved it
was backwards e there Carhartt material
never been done before it was supposed
to be for eight mile the designer and I
who no longer works here but big shout
out Ben You Know Who You Are we sat down
and watched eight mile together and we
sat down and watched eight miles
separately he's like I watched it like
eight times man I said me too I said the
only consistent theme I'm seeing is that
Carhartt jacket and he's like yeah he's
like do you think we could go get
Carhartt and the Carhartt folks sent the
Carhartt material over to the factory
and we made 23 pair of these this is the
original sample look-see actually the
tag is still in there legal might go
crazy but I don't think we had a
contract with him we just shook hands
and said we're gonna do it in just the
way this shoe what it means to the
sneaker game like I charge this one to
the game it's like keep people dreaming
keep people thinking like what's next
nobody knew they wanted a Carhartt
material type of shoe and now I think
the company uh you know Nike Inc we've
done some some shoes with Carhartt as
well so this is a legacy piece
all right
the back stores of these are Kawhi
Leonard was signed to the Jordan brand
he was still in San Antonio Foot Locker
was shooting a commercial with him and
we were trying to figure out somebody to
pair up with Kawhi to bring out his
personality a little bit to make him
comfortable and I was like he loves
Nipsey he loves nipsy hustle and people
are in the room are looking at me like
can we get the Nipsey I was like yeah
just text him it'd be all right yeah so
we're shooting this Footlocker
commercial
we got a fee Bubble Bum it's in San
Antonio he's like don't worry about the
money yo Jay I said you have a new album
or anything coming out he's like yeah
it's called Victory lap and I was like
maybe we could license one of the tracks
for for the commercial they fly down he
still won't take a fee and he killed it
all day long him and Kawhi were vibing I
have some great pictures I could share
with you about it and I was like how can
I say thank you to this guy like he just
wanted a hotel room and a first class
flight for him and his girl to come hang
out with us for the day
and
I said yo your favorite Jordan's or
threes right he's like yeah I said I'm
gonna do something for you so that's how
these came out
um and you see the VL on the side for
Victory lap well I actually have a
Victory lap tattoo right here that's how
much I love nip just as a friend you can
see at the bottom of the VL but these
are really really special there's
probably 10 maybe
I see Phil here everything whether it's
Chris Stapleton whether it's Billy
eilish whether it's Lil Uzi vert whether
it's Trav whether it's Khaled like when
I hear these certain things and sounds I
can equate it to whether they fit within
the culture that we're we've created
here at the Jordan brand
[Music]
one of the top five shoes in my career
as this table rotates man I'm gonna go
here I'm gonna go AJ one low Travis
Scott these are my pair that I beat up
every single day you can see they're
worn these shoes wear great when they're
warm he didn't want Hello he liked the
AJ one high OG one high that we did I
kept sending them pictures of one Lowe's
and back in the day they had a fatter
tongue they're a little bit higher and
he's like bro don't send me no more
pictures bro I'm and he just stop ask
answering and I'm like oh
and then one day I'm sitting in my
office I'm looking at his one AJ one
high OG and I'm like
call Paul Ceviche it was a designer at
the time for us and said Paulie come
down to my office man I got an idea
I said can you make this a low he was
like yeah and I said don't do the fat
tongue like he's trav's been wearing a
ton of dunks like I've been paying
attention when we're around him I
haven't said nothing and I was like
maybe just maybe he might like him he
comes to campus we're going through his
apparel for his AJ one high Paulie
breaks these out and he starts screaming
I
oh my gosh he calls Chase Chase B on the
phone Chase look Chase is like what in
the world what what are y'all doing over
there he's like yo Trav went to the
bathroom
change his clothes put on the hoodie the
shorts these shoes and kept looking down
he's like man they gonna sit right with
jeans he's talking to himself he's like
yo looks at me gives me a dirty look
you fooled me bro and I said nah I just
been watching you you know like that's
what family does right like I'm paying
attention to him that's another secret
sauce it's like you have to be very
selfless to do this job it's not about
me ever I've seen old people young
people little kids big kids it doesn't
matter like this kind of validates
what
Jordan is to me because it's for
everyone you know it's just not a
certain subset of culture it's the
Jordan culture that we've created and
built over time and you know the secret
to the the play shoes and the brown is
is Texas and the dirt and him being at
Granny's house and wearing play shoes
and not caring if you mess them up or
not and that's exactly what these are I
feel like they look better worn them
than brand new out the box so wear your
sneakers people
Eminem
a little bit of a business driver for us
because
Paul calls and says hey M's
confidentially M's performing at Super
Why I'm holding them opposite for a
reason but look at that look at that
it's iconic
along with the Jumpman it's crazy it's
absolutely insane to me and on the
inside you got the mask you got the
Shady Records logo on the back Slim
Shady like he was coming back at Slim
Shady there's actually ones with black
tabs on the back so M couldn't figure
out which one to wear so he won one of
each if you go back and look at the
video at the Super Bowl choose the right
Partners that's authentic to you and it
comes through every single time
[Music]
Legends of Summer and if you when you
guys see the breath of what Legend this
summer really is from Justin Timberlake
and I got a phone call from Justin and
these are like I said long-term
relationships sometimes we can go months
without talking but it's family you
picking up the phone he's like yo I'm
going on a tour with Jay-Z we're gonna
call it Legends Of Summer it's more of a
suit and tie feel so I get off the phone
when I'm texting Tinker where you at I
need you tinker's like what do you need
I said I need you bro he's like what's
happening you're excited for once and I
was like yeah yeah I'm excited so he's
Tinker starting to listen to it in his
office he started sketching he started
drawing his iPad and he comes up with
this reflective type of things if you
put a light on this
Tinker is amazing because he's like
they're gonna be on stage and there's
gonna be lights and it'll pop and what
happens is as I'm walking back across to
my office Justin calls me again yo we
gotta pivot I was like what's the pivot
the stage is Gonna Be Blood Red we need
all red shoes I'm like what I said well
I got Tigger and I didn't even tell
Taylor because I wanted him to keep
going because I just knew it was really
really good
then one of the developers actually came
up with this Dorothy Justin named it he
loves naming Shoes by the way y'all
probably know that and what happened was
there's a two there's a three there's a
couple more ones we ended up with so
many shoes here because they had only 15
dates I was trying to get 15 different
shoes and Justin's like yo
hey do you think this is possible like a
scavenger hunt I said well what do you
want to do JT he's like I want to give
him away
after I wear them I'm gonna sign them
put the city put the date and then leave
them at an iconic location there's
people out there with these and then
there's some friends and family still
floating around but like this as a set
is in my top five those Legends of the
summer are like my babies
because it was almost like we weren't
supposed to do it it couldn't have been
done in the time frame but we did it and
we did it with a Retro 2 who nobody was
checking for twos at the time the three
what everybody's talking about but the
ones there's a precursor to what what
was to come of of once
this shoe the biggie Air Jordan 13
happened through relationships Mrs
Wallace Waynesboro Big East manager
shout out James Cruz one of my close
friends like this shoe was done in 2017
and we were gonna do it for biggies I
think 45th birthday we wanted to
celebrate big and this shoe was actually
coming out black red 13. black cat we're
looking at it I'm like black and red
lumberjacked like you know rapping duke
the high the high you never know rap
could take you this far so you got
Chris's face you got if you don't know
you know black and red Lumberjack and
the thing I love about these 50th
Anniversary hip-hop the year 2023 we
held on to him since 2017 because we're
trying to find the right moment this job
is also about a lot of patience these
things just don't happen they just don't
I wish they did but this you know
blessed by the guy Mrs Wallace and Wayne
and I said hey we should auction instead
of just giving you the friends and
family pairs we should auction them off
and raise money for the Christopher
Wallace foundation and we ended up
raising over 500 000 and we're working
with the foundation now from our black
community commitment standpoint from the
Jordan brand
um which you know we started with George
Floyd it's it's 100 million dollars over
10 years and Michael yay 50 the brand
gave 50 and this is just to show you
like
it says it right there it was all a
dream like
didn't know how much money we were going
to raise if we're gonna raise anything
but when you're raising money for a
charity doesn't matter you're it's going
to a great cause so you know Mrs Wallace
used to do small things like take the
elders in her community like to buffets
and stuff that are in Brooklyn that
don't have a chance to go out now she
can expand this into education like the
mission of of the the foundation because
for me that's what it's about as well as
giving back but his legacy lives on
Michael born in Brooklyn guess what this
guy's born in Brooklyn
Spike Lee Red Hook Mike Tyson Carmelo
Anthony born in Brooklyn like we have so
many ties within this family and we're
all so close and we all help each other
get to the next level I felt like that
took the Christopher Wallace Foundation
to the next level where they can help
some kids in Brooklyn and Red Hook where
you know kids are struggling these days
and
um you know where he was born and he's
still able to give back that's pretty
that's pretty powerful
[Music]
foreign
s was the the bread ones for some reason
I think my son Christian has my bread
ones I think I couldn't find them so I
had to wear the patent leather ones but
even better inside of these is the word
family
so when you see me with these on it's a
special moment special occasion it's 85
and I see these Breads and I'm like whoa
black and red shoes look at those white
ones I wonder how I get them and to get
those AJ one breads I've cut grass I was
20 short and my mom was like looking at
my dad like yo he's worked really hard
there's nobody else's grass cut
so she's like I'm gonna give him the 20
bucks he's like yeah you go do what you
do you know and the marketing around it
the Mystique already of Michael Jordan
me having watched him play being a big
NC State fan and ACC and Tobacco Road
and Lynn bias is in our backyard and I
slept with him on I slept with them next
to my nightstand I wiped them off of the
ragwees and the toothbrush thing wasn't
even invented then I was doing that too
I didn't want my shoes to get messed up
they meant so much to me because of what
that man stood for what Michael Jordan
was doing on the basketball court
foreign
[Music]
take these off because they're just new
they're just new they're newer
um
I got a
kill two more
this is the craziest game ever man this
game is terrible
[Laughter]
I'm used to winning I feel like I'm
losing
um oh
lumberjack
Souls the Notorious B.I.G his logo now
you gotta go from three to two I'm gonna
go with the old beaters
man look how the business worked out
alone
yeah I'm sticking with the OG sticking
with the first ones changed my life
never thought I'd work at Nike didn't
know didn't didn't understand didn't
know anything about the sneaker game but
when you look back on it and how things
play out it's pretty damn cool that you
know this is what my first Jordan and
that I work at this place it's it's
amazing you know I want to say thank you
to to H Larry Michael obviously and
Michael's team Este and Curtis they
believed in me and I believed in myself
and it doesn't get much better than
these
foreign
[Music]
you know looking far out what I see is
um Indian sneaker culture coming from
that continent Africa afrobeats is
amazing it's the new pop music
it's time Africa and I know it is Retros
are great we need to make a shoe that
takes us into the next millennium
I think we have that in somebody named
Travis Scott Cala does a great job every
team has a champion that's college for
us he's a champion J Balvin takes us to
the Latino World Tiana Taylor she's
coming up with a launch here shortly you
know from a female point of view not
everyone can sell a shoe guys like this
is hard you got to work hard for it you
got to show people something different
that's my challenge to the world because
the story again is an American Dream
you can do it two kids you could do it
to adults dream dream big I've had
plenty of people try to put me in a box
before oh he only does this and then I
show them something different Michael
did it too he don't play no defense
defensive player of the year
he can't shoot free throw shoots one
with his eyes closed so I take those
lessons from him
and
know that like
when you're prepared you're not scared
you can talk to somebody you don't even
know if you pass them in the airport and
they have on some Jordans you like if
you say nice shoes you've made their day
it's amazing this thing is bigger than
basketball